The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: All right.
Good morning, everyone.
And let's get started.
Today's lecture is about a
randomized data structure
called the skip list.
And it's a data structure
that, obviously because it's
randomized, we'd have to do
a probabilistic analysis for.
And we're going to sort of raise
the stakes here a little bit
with respect to
our expectation--
the pun intended of this
data structure-- in the sense
that we're not going to be happy
with just doing an expected
value analysis or to get
what the expectation is
of the search complexity
in a skip list.
We're going to introduce this
notion with high probability,
which is a stronger notion than
just giving you the expected
value or the expectation for
the complexity of a search
algorithm.
And we're going to prove
that under this notion,
that search has a
particular complexity
with high probability.
So we'll get to the with high
probability part a little bit
later in the lecture,
but we're just
going to start off doing some
cool data structure design,
I guess, [INAUDIBLE]
pointing to the skip list.
The skip list is a relatively
young data structure
invented by a guy called
Bill Pugh in 1989,
so not much older than you guys.
It's relatively easy to
implement as you'll see.
I won't really claim
that, but hopefully you'll
be convinced by the time you're
done describing the structure.
Especially in comparison
to balanced trees.
And we can do a comparison after
we do our analysis of the data
structure as to what the
complexity comparisons are
for search and insert
when you take a skip list
and compare it to an
AVL tree, for example,
or a red black tree, et cetera.
In general, when we
have a data structure,
we want it to be dynamic.
The skip list maintains
a dynamic set.
What that means
is not only do you
want to search on
it-- obviously it's
uninteresting to have a static
data structure and do a search.
You want to be able to
change it, want to be
able to insert values into it.
There's a complexity of
insert to worry about.
You want to be able
to delete values.
And the richness of
the data structure
comes from the operations
and the augmentations
you can do on it, and the skip
lists are no exception to that.
So if you want to maintain
a dynamic set of n elements,
and you obviously know a ton
of data structures to do this,
each of which has
different characteristics.
And this is, if you
ignore hash tables,
this is your first real
randomized data structure,
if you're just taking
6006 and this class
might have seen randomized
structures in other classes.
So we're going to try and
do this in order log n time.
As you know with
balanced binary trees,
you can do things in order
log n time, a ton of things,
pretty much everything
that is interesting.
And this, given that
it's randomized,
it's a relatively
easy analysis to show
that the expectation or the
expected value of a search
would be order log
n expected time.
But we're going to, as I
said, raise the stakes,
and we're going to
spend a ton of time
the second half of this showing
the with high probability
result. And that's
a stronger result
than just saying that search
takes expected order log n
time.
All right, so
that's the context.
You can think of a
skip list as beginning
with a simple linked list.
So if we have one link list
and that link list-- let's
first think of this
as being unsorted.
So suppose I have a link
list which is unsorted
and I want to search for a
particular value in this link
list.
And we can assume that this
is a doubly-linked list,
so the arrows go both ways.
You have a pointer, let's say,
just to the first element.
So if you have a
list that's unsorted
and you want to
search for an element,
you would want to do
a membership query.
If there's n elements,
the complexity is?
AUDIENCE: Order n.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Order n.
So a linked list, the search
takes the order n time.
Now let's go ahead and say
that we are sorting this list,
so it's a sorted linked list.
So your values here,
14, 23, 34, 42, 50, 59.
They're sorted in
ascending order.
You still only have a pointer
to the front of the list
and it's a
doubly-linked list, what
is the complexity of search
in the sorted link list?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Log n.
Oh, I wanted to hear that.
Because it is?
AUDIENCE: Order n.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: It's order n.
log n is-- yeah, that
was a trick question.
Because I liked that answer,
the person who said log n
gets a Frisbee.
This person won't admit.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, it was you.
OK, all right.
There you go.
All right.
So log n would imply that
you have random access.
If you have an array that's
sorted and you can go
[? AFi, ?] and you can go
[? AFi ?] divided by 2,
or [? AF2i ?] and you can
go directly to that element,
then you can do binary search
and you can get a log n,
order log in.
But here, the sorting
actually doesn't help you
with respect to the
search simply because you
have to start from
the beginning,
from the front of the list,
and you've got to keep walking.
The only place that it helps you
is that if you know it's sorted
and you're looking
for 37, you can
stop after you see 42, right?
That's pretty much the only
place that it helps you.
But it's still
order n because that
could happen-- on
average is going
to happen halfway through the
list for a given membership
query.
So it's still order n
for a sorted link list.
But now let's say that we
had two sorted link lists.
And how are these two
link lists structured?
Well, they're structured
in a certain way,
and let me draw our canonical
example for skip list
that I'm going to
keep coming back to.
So I won't erase this, but I'll
draw one out-- 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9-- 9 elements.
So that's my first
list which is sorted,
and so I have 14, 23, 34,
42, 50, 59, 66, 72, and 79.
What I'm going to have
now is another list sort
of on top of this.
I can move from top
to bottom, et cetera.
But I'm not going
to have elements
on top of each bottom element.
By convention, I'm
going to have elements
on top of the first
element, regardless
of how many lists I have.
We only have two at this point.
And so I see a 14, which
is exactly the same element
duplicated up on the top list.
And that list is
also sorted, but I
won't have all of the
elements in the top list.
I'm just picking a couple here.
So I've got 34, 42--
they're adjacent here--
and then I go all
the way up to 72,
and I duplicate it, et cetera.
Now, this looks kind of random.
Anybody recognize these numbers?
No one from the great
City of New York?
No?
Yup, yup.
AUDIENCE: On the subway stops?
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Yeah, subway
stops on the Seventh Avenue
Express Line.
So this is exactly the notion
of a skip list, the fact
that you have--
could you stand up?
Great.
All right.
So the notion here
is that you don't
have to make a lot of stops if
you know you have to go far.
So if you want to go from
14th Street to 72nd Street,
you just take the express line.
But if you want to go to 66th
Street, what would you do?
AUDIENCE: Go to 72nd
and then go back.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
Well, that's one way.
That's one way.
That's not the way I wanted.
The way we're going
to do this is we're
not going to overshoot.
So we want to minimize
distance, let's say.
So our secondary
thing is going to be
minimizing distance travel.
And so you're going to pop
up the express line, go
all the way to 42nd
Street, and you're
going to say if I go to the
next stop on the Express Line,
I'm going too far.
And so you're going to pop
down to the local line.
So you can think of this as
being link list L0 and link
list L1.
You're going to pop
down, and then you're
going to go to 66th Street.
So search 66 will be
going from 14 to 42
on L1, and then from 42,
let's just say that's walking.
42 to 42, L1 to L0.
And then 42 to 66 on L0.
So that's the basic
notion of a skip list.
So you can see that it's
really pretty simple.
What we're going to do
now is do two things.
I want to think about this
double-sorted list as a data
structure in its own right
before I dive into skip lists
in general.
And I want to analyze at some
level, the best case situation
for worst case complexity.
And by that I mean I want to
structure the express stops
in the best manner possible.
These stops are very
structured for passengers
because they figured fancy
stops on 42nd Avenue, whatever--
fancy stores.
Everybody wants to go there
and so on and so forth.
So you have 34 pretty close
to 42 because they're both
popular destinations.
But let's say that
things where I
guess more egalitarian and
randomized, if you will.
And what I want to do
is I want to structure
this double-sorted list so
I get the best worst case
complexity for search.
And so let's do that.
And before I do that, let me
write out the search algorithm,
which is going to be important.
I want you to assimilate
this, keep it in your head
because we're going
to analyze search
pretty much for the rest
of the morning here.
And so I'll write this down.
You've got a sense of what it
is based on what I just did here
with this example of 66,
but worth writing down.
We're going to walk right
in the top linked list,
so this is simply
for two linked lists,
and we'll generalize
at some point.
So we want to walk right
in the top linked list, L1,
until going right
would go too far.
Now, there was this answer with
72, which I kind of dismissed.
But there's no reason
why you can't overshoot
one stop and go backwards.
It would just be a
different search algorithm.
It's not something we're
going to analyze here.
It turns out in analyzing that
with high probability would
be even more painful
than the painful analysis
we're going to do.
So we won't go there.
And then we walk down
to the bottom list.
And the bottom
list we'll call L0.
And walk right in L0 until
the element is found or not.
And you know that
if you've overshot.
So if you're looking here for
route 67, when you get to 72
here-- you've seen
66 and you get to 72
and you're looking
for 67, search fails.
It stops and fails.
Doesn't succeed in this case.
So that's what we
got for search.
And that's our two
linked list argument.
Now, our analysis essentially
says what I have is
I'm walking right at
the bottom list here,
and my top list is L1,
so I start with L1.
And my search cost
is going to be
approximately the length of L1.
The worst case analysis,
I could go all the way
on the top list-- it's possible.
But for a given value, I'm
going to be looking at only
a portion of the bottom list.
I'm not going to go all the
way on the bottom list ever.
I'm only going to be
looking at a portion of it.
So it's going to be
L0 divided by L1,
if I have interspersed my
express stops in a uniform way.
So there's no reason--
if I have 100 elements
in the bottom list,
and if I had five,
just for argument sake,
five in the top list,
then I'd put them at, let's
say, the 0 position, 20, 40, 60,
et cetera.
So I want to have
roughly equal spacings.
But we need to make that
a little more concrete,
and a little more precise.
And what I'm saying
here simply is
that this is the cost of
traversal in the top list,
and this is the cost of
traversal in the bottom list,
because I'm not going to go
all the way in the bottom list.
I'm only going to go a
portion on the bottom list.
Everybody gets that?
Yup?
All right, good.
So if I want to minimize
this cost, which
is going to tell
me how to scatter
these elements in the top list,
how to choose my express stops,
if you will-- I want to
scatter these in a uniform way,
then this is minimized
when terms are equal.
You could go off and
differentiate and do that.
It's fairly standard.
And what you end up getting
is you want to get L1 square
equals L0 equals n.
So all of the elements are
down at the bottom list,
and so the cardinality
of the bottom list is n.
And roughly speaking, you're
going to end up optimizing,
if you have this satisfied,
which means that L1 is
going to be square root of n.
OK?
So what you've done here is
you've said a bunch of things,
actually.
You've decided how
many elements are
going to be in your top list.
If there's n elements
in the bottom list,
you want to have the square root
of n elements in the top list.
And not only that,
in order to make sure
that this works properly, and
that you don't get a worse case
cost that is not
optimal, you do have
to intersperse the
square root of n elements
at regular intervals in
relation to the bottom list
on the top list.
OK, so pictorially
what this means is it's
not what you have here.
What you really
want is something
that, let's say, looks like
this where this part here
is square root of n elements
up until that point,
and then let's say we
go from here to here
or square root of n
elements, and maybe I'll
have a 66 here because
that's exactly where I
want my square root of n.
Basically, three
elements in between.
So I got 66 here, et cetera.
I mean I chose n to be
a particular value here,
but you get the picture.
So the search now, as you can
see if you just add those up
you get square root
of n here, and you
got n divided by
square root of n here.
So that's square
root of n as well.
So the search cost is
order square root of n.
And so that's it.
That's the first
generalization, and really
the most important
one, that comes
from going from a
single sorted list
to an approximation
of a skip list.
So what do you do if you
want to make things better?
So we want to make
things better?
Are we happy with
square root of n?
AUDIENCE: No.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: No.
Well, what's our target?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
Log n, obviously.
Well, I guess you can
argue that our target may
be order 1 at some point,
but for today's lecture
it is order log n
with high probability.
We'll leave it at that.
And so what do you do if
you want to go this way
and generalize?
You simply add more lists.
I mean it seems to be pretty
much the only thing we
could do here.
So let's go ahead
and add a third list.
So if you have two
sorted lists, that
implies I have 2
square root of n.
If I want to be explicit
about the constant in terms
of the search cost,
assuming things
are interspersed exactly right.
Keep that in mind because
that is going to go away
when we go and randomize.
We're going to be flipping
coins and things like that.
But so far, things
are very structured.
What do you think-- we won't
do this analysis-- the cost is
going to be if I
intersperse optimally, what
is the cost going
to be for a search
when I have three sorted lists?
AUDIENCE: Cube root.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Cube root.
Great guess.
Who said cube root?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: You
already have a Frisbee.
Give it to a friend.
I need to get rid of these.
So it's going to be cube
root, and the constant
in front of that is going to be?
AUDIENCE: 3.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: 3.
So you have-- right?
So let's just keep going.
You have k sorted lists.
You're going to have k
times the k-th root of n.
That's what you got.
And I'm not going to
bother drawing this,
but essentially
what happens is you
are making the same number
of moves which corresponds
to the root of n, the
corresponding root of n,
at every level.
And the last thing we have to do
to get a sense for what happens
here is we have log n sorted
lists, so the number of levels
here is log n.
So this is starting to look kind
of familiar because it borrows
from other data structures.
And what this is I'm just going
to substitute log n for k,
and I got this kind
of scary looking--
I was scared the
first time I saw this.
Oh, this is n.
It's the log n-th root of n, OK?
And so it's kind
of scary looking.
But what is the log n-th
root of n-- and we can assume
that n is a power of two?
AUDIENCE: 2.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: 2, exactly.
It's not that scary
looking, and that's
because I'm not a mathematician.
That's why I was scared.
So 2 log n.
All right.
So that's it.
So you get a sense of how
this works now, right?
We haven't talked about
randomized structures yet,
but I've given you
the template that's
associated with the skip list,
which essentially says what I'm
going to have are-- if it was
static data items and n was
a power of two, then
essentially what
I'm saying is I'm going to
have a bunch of items, n items,
at the bottom.
I'm going to have n over
2 items at the list that's
just immediately above.
And each of them are
going to be alternating.
You're going to have
an item in between.
And then on the top I'm
going to see n over 4 items,
and so on and so forth.
What does that look like?
Kind of looks like
a tree, right?
I mean it doesn't
have the structure
of a tree in the sense
of the edges of a tree.
It's quite different
because you're
connecting things differently.
You have all the
leaves connected down
at the bottom of
this so-called tree
with this doubly linked
list, but it has the triangle
structure of a tree.
And that's where the
log n comes from.
So this is would
all be wonderful
if this were a static set.
And n doesn't have to be a
power of 2-- you could pad it,
and so on and so forth.
But the big thing here
is that we haven't quite
accomplished what
we set out to do,
even though we seem to have
this log n cost for search.
But it's all based on a static
set which doesn't change.
And the problem, of course, is
that you could have deletions.
You want to take away 42.
For some reason you
can't go to 42nd Avenue,
or I guess art-- you
can't go to [INAUDIBLE]
would be a better example.
So stuff breaks, right?
And so you take stuff out
and you insert things in.
Suppose I wanted to insert
60, 61, 62, 63, and 64
into that list that I have?
What would happen?
Yeah, you're shaking your head.
I mean that log n would go
away, so it would be a problem.
But what we have
to do now is move
to the probabilistic domain.
We have to think
about what happens
when we insert elements.
We need an algorithm for insert.
So then we can start with the
null list and build it up.
And then you start
with a null list
and you have a randomized
algorithm for insert,
it ain't going to
look that pretty.
It's going to look random.
But you have to have a
certain amount of structure
so you can still get
your order log n.
So you have to do the
insertion appropriately.
So that's what we
have to do next.
But any questions
about that complexity
that I have up there?
All right, good.
I want a canonical
example of a list here,
and I kind of ran out
of room over there,
so bear with me as I draw you
a more sophisticated skip list
that has a few more levels.
And the reason for this is
it's only interesting when
you have three or more levels.
The search algorithm
is kind of the same.
You go up top and when
you overshoot you pop down
one level, and then you do
the same thing over and over.
But we are going
to have to bound
the number of levels in the skip
list in a probabilistic way.
We have to actually discover
the expected number of levels
because we're going to be doing
inserts in a randomized way.
And so it's worthwhile
having a picture that's
a little more interesting than
the picture of the two linked
lists that I had up there.
So I'm going to leave this on
for the rest of the lecture.
So that's our bottom,
and that hasn't changed
from our previous examples.
I'm not going to bother drawing
the horizontal connections.
When you see things adjacent
horizontally at the same level,
assume that they're all
connected-- all of them.
And so I have four levels here.
And you can think of this
as being the entire list
or part of it.
Just to delineate
things nicely, we'll
assume that 79, which
is the last element,
is all the way up
at the top as well.
Sort of the terminus,
termini, corresponding
to our analogy of subways.
And so that's our
top-most level.
And then I might have
50 here at this level,
or so that looks like.
I will have 50, so
the invariant here,
and that's another reason
I want to draw this out,
is that if you have a station
at highest level, then
you will have-- it's got
to be sitting on something.
So if you've got a 79 at
level four, or level three
here if this is L0, then you
will see 79 at L2, L1, and L0.
And if you see 50 here,
it's not in L3 so that's OK,
but it's in L2, so it's
got to be at L1 as well.
Of course you know that
everything is down at L1,
so this is interesting from a
standpoint of the relationship
between Li and Li plus 1 where
i is greater than or equal to 1.
So the implication is that if
you see it at at Li plus 1,
it's going to be at
Li and Li minus 1
if that happens to
exist, et cetera.
And so one last thing
here just to finish it up.
I got 34 here, which is
an additional thing which
ends there.
So the highest level is
this second level or L1.
This is 66.
And then that's it.
So that's our skip list.
So if you wanted to search
for 72, you would start here,
and then you'd go to 79,
or you'd look and say,
oh, 79 is too far, so I'm
going to pop down a level.
And then you'd say 50, oh, good.
I can get to 50.
79 is too far, so I'm
going to pop down a level.
And then you go to 66--
79 is too far-- and at 66,
you pop down a level and
then you go 66 to 72.
So same as what we had before.
Hopefully it's not
too complicated.
So that's our skip list.
It's still looking
pretty structured,
looking pretty regular.
But if I start
taking that and start
inserting things
and deleting things,
it could become quite irregular.
I could take away
23, for example.
And there's nothing
that's stopping me
from taking away 34 or 79.
You've got to delete
an element, you've
got to delete an element.
I mean the fact that
it's in four levels
shouldn't make a difference.
And so that's something
to keep in mind.
So this could get pretty messy.
So let's talk about
insert, and I've
spent a bunch of time skirting
around the issue of what
exactly happens when
you insert an element.
Turns out delete is pretty easy.
Insert is more interesting.
Let's do insert.
To insert an element
x into a skip list,
the first thing
we're going to do
is search to figure out where
x fits into the bottom list.
So you do a search just like
you would if you were just
doing a search.
You always insert into
the appropriate position.
So if there's a
single sorted list,
that would pretty much be it.
And so that part is easy.
If you want to insert 67, you
do all of the search operations
that I just went
over, and then you
insert 67 between 66 and 72.
So do your pointer
manipulations, what have you,
and you're good.
But you're not done yet, because
you want this to be a skip list
and you want this to
have expected search
over any random query as
the list grows and shrinks
of order log n, expectation,
and also with high probability.
So what you're going to have to
do is when you start inserting,
you're going to have
to decide if you're
going to what is called
promote these elements or not.
And the notion of a
promotion is that you
are going up and duplicating
this inserted element
some number of levels up.
So if you just look
at how this works,
it's really pretty
straightforward.
What is going to happen is
simply that let's say I have 67
and I'm going to insert
it between 66 and 72.
That much is a given.
That is deterministic.
Then I'm going to flip a
coin or spin a Frisbee.
I like this better.
I'm not sure if this
is biased or not.
It's probably seriously biased.
[LAUGHTER]
Would it ever go the
other way is the question.
Would it ever?
No.
All right.
So we've got a problem here.
I think we might have to
do something like that.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm procrastinating.
I don't want to teach the
rest of this material.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
Let's go, let's go.
So I'd like to insert
into some of the lists,
and the big question
is which ones?
It's going to be really cool.
I'm just going to flip
coins, fair coins,
and decide how much to
promote these elements.
So flip fair coin.
If heads, promote x to the
next level up, and repeat.
Else, if you ever get
a tails, you stop.
And this next level up
may be newly created.
So what might happen with the
67 is that you stick it in here,
and it might happen that
the first time you flip you
get a tails, in which
case, 67 is going
to just be at the bottom list.
But if you get one heads,
then you're not only
going to put 67 in
here, you're going
to put 67 up here as well.
And you're going to flip again.
And if you get a heads again,
you're going to put 67 up here.
And if you get a
heads again, you're
going to create a
new list up there,
and at this point when
you create the new list,
it's only going
to be 67 up there.
And that's going to be
the front of your list,
because that's the one element
that you're duplicating.
So you're going to keep
going until you get a tails.
Now, that's why this
coin had better be fair.
So you're going to
keep going and you're
going to keep adding.
Every time you insert
there's a potential
for increasing the number
of levels in this list.
Now, the number
of levels is going
to be bounded in expectation
with a high probability
of regular
expectation, but I want
to make it clear that
every time you insert,
if you get a chain
of heads, you're
going to be adding levels.
And so the first time you
get a tails, you just stop.
You just stop.
So you can see that this can
get pretty messy pretty quick.
And especially if you were
starting from ground zero
and adding 14, 23--
all of those things,
the bottom is going
to look exactly
like it looks now because
you're going to put it in there.
It's deterministic.
But the very next level after
that looked pretty messy.
You could have all of
them chunked up here,
and a big gap, et
cetera, et cetera.
So it's all about
randomized search cost.
The worse case cost here
is going to be order n.
Worst case cost is
going to be order n,
because you have no idea
where these things are
going to end up.
But the randomized cost
is what's cool about this.
Any questions about
insert or anything I said?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Is worse
case really order n?
What if you had a really
long, like a lot of lists
on top of each other, and
you start at the top of that
and you had to walk all
the way [INAUDIBLE]?
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Well, you go
n down and n this way, right?
You would be checking
so it would be order n.
AUDIENCE: So it's
[? bounded ?] by n?
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
Yeah, the worst case.
AUDIENCE: Worse
case is infinity.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
Worse case is infinity.
Oh, in that sense, yeah.
OK.
Well, n elements, Eric is right.
So what is happening
here is that you
have a small probability
that you will
keep flipping heads forever.
So at some level, if you
somehow take that away and use
Frisbees instead
or you truncate it.
Let's say at some point you
ended up saying that you only
have n levels total.
So it's not a-- I
should have gone there.
The question has to
be posed a little more
precisely for the
answer to be order n.
You have to have some more
limitations to avoid the case
that Eric just mentioned, which
is in the randomized situation
you will have the
possibility of getting
an infinite number of heads.
Yeah, question back there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Yes, you
can certainly do capping
and you can do a
bunch of other things.
It ends up becoming
something which is not
as clean as what you have here.
The analysis is messy.
And it's sort of in between
a randomized data structure,
a purely randomized
data structure,
and a deterministic one.
I think the important
thing to bring out here
is the worst case is much
worse than order log n, OK?
Cool.
Good.
Thanks for those questions.
And so what we have here now is
an insert algorithm that could
make things look pretty messy.
I'm going to leave the insert
up here, and that, of course,
is part of that.
Now, for the rest
of the lecture we're
going to talk about why
skip lists are good.
And we're going to justify
this randomized data structure
and show lots of nice
results with respect
to the expectation on the
number of levels, expectation
on the number of
moves in a search,
regardless of what items
you're inserting and deleting.
One last thing.
To delete an item,
you just delete it.
You find it, search, and
delete at all levels.
So you can't leave it
in any of the levels.
So you find it, and you have
to have the pointers set up
properly-- move the
previous pointer over
to the next one, et
cetera, et cetera.
We won't get into
that here, but you
have to do the delete
at every level.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: So what happens
if you inserted 10s
and you flip off a tail?
So that's like your
first element is not
going to go up all the way,
and then have you do search.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
So typically what
happens is you need to
have a minus infinity here.
And that's a good point.
It's a corner case.
You have to have a
minus infinity that
goes up all the way.
Good question.
So the question was what happens
if I had something less than 14
and I inserted it?
Well, that doesn't
happen because nothing
is less than minus infinity,
and that goes up all the way.
But thanks for bringing it up.
And so we're going to do
a little warm-up Lemma.
I don't know if
you've ever heard
these two terms in juxtaposition
like this-- warm up and Lemma.
But here you go, your
first warm-up Lemma.
I guess you'd never
have a warm-up theorem.
It's a warm-up Lemma for
this theorem, which is
going to take a while to prove.
This comes down to trying to
get a sense of how many levels
you're going to have from
a probabilistic standpoint.
The number of levels in
an n element skip list
is order log n.
And I'm going to now define
the term with high probability.
So what does this mean exactly?
Well, what this
means is order log n
is something like c
log n plus a constant.
Let's ignore the constant
and let's stick with c log n.
And with high probability
is a probability
that is really a
function of n and alpha.
And you have this inverse
polynomial relationship
in the sense that
obviously as n grows here,
an alpha-- we'll assume that
alpha is greater than the 1--
you are going to get a
decrease in this quantity.
So this is going to get closer
and closer to 1 as n grows.
So that's the difference
between with high probability
and just sort of giving you
an expectation number where
you have no such guarantees.
What is interesting about
this is that as n grows,
you're going to get a higher
and higher probability.
And this constant c is going
to be related to alpha.
That's the other thing that's
interesting about this.
So it's like saying-- and
you can kind of say this
for using Chernoff bounds that
we'll get to in a few minutes,
even for expectation as well.
But what this says is that
if, for example, c doubled,
then you are saying that
your number of levels
is order 4 log n.
I mean I understand that that
doesn't make too much sense,
but it's less than or equal
to 4 log n plus a constant.
And that 4 is going to get
reflected in the alpha here.
When the 4 goes from 4 to
8, the alpha increases.
So the more room that you have
with respect to this constant,
the higher the probability.
It becomes an
overwhelming probability
that you're going to be
within those number of levels.
So maybe there's
an 80% probability
that you're within 2 log n.
But there's a
99.99999% probability
that you're within 4 log
n, and so on and so forth.
So that's the kind of thing
that with the high probability
analysis tells you explicitly.
And so you can do that,
you can do this analysis
fairly straightforwardly.
And let me do that
on a different board.
Let me go ahead and
do that over here.
Actually, I don't
really need this.
So let's do that over here.
And so this is our first with
high probability analysis.
And I want to prove
that warm-up Lemma.
So usually what you
do here is you look
at the failure probability.
So with high
probability is typically
something that
looks like 1 minus 1
divided by n raised to alpha.
And this part here is
the failure probability.
And that's typically
what you analyze
and what we're
going to do today.
So the failure probability
is that it's not less
than c log n levels, is the
complement of what we just
looked at, which is the
probability that it's strictly
greater than c log n levels.
And that's the probability
that some element gets promoted
greater than c log n times.
So why would you have
more than c log n levels?
It's essentially because
you inserted something
and that element got promoted
strictly greater than c
log n times, which
obviously implies that you
had the sequence
of heads, and we'll
get to that in just a second.
But before we go to that
step of figuring out
exactly what's going on here
as to why this got promoted
and what the probability
of each promotion
is, what I have here is I
have a sequence of inserts
potentially that
I have to analyze.
And in general, when I
have an n element list,
I'm going to assume that
each of these elements
got inserted into the
list at some point.
So I've had n inserts.
And we just look at the case
where you have n inserts,
you could have deletes, and so
you could have more inserts,
but it won't really
change anything.
You have n inserts corresponding
to each of these elements,
and one of those n elements got
promoted in this failure case
greater than c log n times.
That's essentially
what's happened here.
And so you don't know which
one, but you can typically
do this in with high
probability analysis
because the probabilities
are so small
and they're inverse
polynomials, polynomials like n
raised to alpha.
You can use what's
called the union bound
that I'm sure you've used before
in some context or the other.
And you essentially
say that this
is less than or equal
to the probability
that a particular element x.
So you just pick an element,
arbitrary element x,
but you pick one.
Gets promoted greater
than c log n times.
So you have a small probability.
You have no idea whether these
events are independent or not.
The union bound
doesn't care about it.
It's like saying you've got
a 0.001 probability that any
of these elements could get
promoted greater than c log n
times, and there's
10 of those elements.
You don't know whether they're
independent events or not,
but you can certainly
use the union
bound that says the overall
failure probability is going
to be less than or equal to
n equals 10, in my example,
times that 0.001.
That's basically it.
Now you can go off
and say, what does it
mean for an element
to get promoted?
What actually has to happen
for an element to get promoted?
And you have n times 1
over 2, because you're
flipping a fair
coin, and you are
getting a c log n heads here.
You flip and you
get one promotion.
There's two levels
associated with a promotion,
the level you came from
and the level you went to.
And so a promotion
is a move, so you're
going to have one more level.
If you count levels, then you
have the number of promotions,
right?
That's just simply
corresponds to taking this 1/2
and raising it to c log n,
because that's essentially
the number of
promotions you have.
And you got n 1/2 c log n,
and what does that turn into?
What is n times 1/2 c log n?
1 over 2 raised to
log n would give you?
2 raised to log ns?
Is n, right?
So you got n divided
by n raised to c, which
is 1 divided by n
raised to c minus 1,
which is 1 divided by n
raised to alpha where alpha
is c minus 1.
So that's it.
That's our first with
high probability analysis.
Not too hard.
What I've done is done
exactly what I just told you
that the notion of with
high probability is.
You have a failure
probability that is related.
Inverse polynomial and the
degree of the polynomial alpha
is related to c.
And so that's what
I have out there,
but c equals-- what did it have?
Alpha equals c minus 1
or c equals alpha plus 1.
So what I've done here
is done an analysis
that tells you with high
probability how many levels
I'm going to have given
my insert algorithm.
So this is the first part
of what we'd like to show.
This just tells us
how big this skip list
is going to grow vertically.
It doesn't tell us anything
about the structure of the list
internally as to whether
the randomization is going
to cause that pretty
structure that you see up
here to be completely messed up
to the point where we don't get
order log n search complexity,
because we are spending way too
much time let's say on the
bottom list or the list
just above the bottom
list, et cetera.
So we need to get a sense of
how the structure corresponding
to the skip list, whether it's
going to look somewhat uniform
or not.
We have to categorize
that, and the only way
we're going to
characterize that is
by analyzing search and
counting the number of moves
that a search makes.
And the reason it's
more complicated
than what you see up there
is that in a search, as you
can see, you're going to be
moving at different levels.
You're going to be
moving at the top level.
Maybe at relatively
small number of moves,
you're going to pop down one,
move a few moves at that level,
pop down, et cetera, et cetera.
So there's a lot of things
going on in search which
happen at different
levels, and the total cost
is going to have to
be all of the moves.
So we're going to think
about all of the moves--
up moves, down moves,
and add them all up.
They all have to be order
log n with high probability.
There's no getting around that
because each of them costs you.
So that's the thing that we'll
spend the next 20 minutes on.
And the theorem that we
like to prove for search
is that-- this is
what I just said--
any search in an n element skip
list costs order log n w.h.p.
So it doesn't matter how
this skip list looks.
There's n elements,
they got inserted
using the insert
algorithm-- that's
important to know if you're
going to have to use that.
And when I do a search for an
element, it may be in there,
it may not be in there.
Doesn't really matter.
We'll assume a
successful search.
That is going to cost me order
log n with high probability.
And the cool idea here in
terms of analyzing the search
in order to figure out
how we're going to add up
all of these moves is
we're going to analyze
the search backwards.
So that's a cool idea.
So what does that mean exactly?
Well, what that
means is that we're
going to think
about this b search,
which think of it as the
backward search, starts--
it actually ends, so that's what
I'm writing in brackets here,
at the node in the bottom list.
So we're assuming a successful
search, as I mentioned before.
Otherwise, the point would
just be in between two members.
You know that it's not in there
because you're looking for 67
and you see 66 to your
left and 72 to your right.
So either way it
works, but keep in mind
that it's a successful
search because it just makes
things a little bit easier.
Now, at each node that we
visit, what we're going to do
is we're going to say that
if the node was not promoted
higher, then what
actually happened here
was that when you inserted
that particular element,
you got a tails.
Because otherwise you
would have gotten a heads,
that element would have
been promoted higher.
Then you go-- and
that really means
that you came from the left-hand
side, so you make a left move.
Now, search of course makes
down moves and right moves,
but this is a backward search
so it's going to make left moves
and up moves.
What else do I have here?
Running out of room, so let
me-- let's continue with that.
All right.
And now the case is if
the node was promoted
higher, that means
we got heads here
in that particular insertion.
Then we go, and that means
that during the search
we came from upstairs.
And then lastly, we
stop, which means
we start when we reach the top
level or minus infinity if we
go all the way back.
So that's it.
A lot of writing here, but
this should make things clear.
So let's say that
we're searching for 66.
I want to trace through what
the backwards path would
look like, and keep that
code in mind as I do this.
So I'm searching for
66, and obviously, we
know how to find it.
We've done that.
But let's go backwards
as to what exactly
happened when we look for 66.
When we look for 66, right at
this point when you see 66,
where would you have come from?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: You'd
have come from the top.
And so if you go look
at what happens here,
the node when it got inserted
was promoted one level.
So that means that you would go
up top in the backward search
first.
Your first move would
be going up like that.
Now, if there's a 66 up there,
you would go up one more.
But there's not, so you go left.
You go to 50.
And when you have a 50 up here,
would you stay on this level?
AUDIENCE: No.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: No.
You'd go up to 50
because the first chance
you get you want to get
up to the higher levels.
And again, this 50 was
promoted so you go up there,
and you go to 14, and pretty
much that's the end of that.
So this would look like you go
like that, you have an up move,
then you have a left move--
different colors here
would be good-- then
you have an up move,
and a left, and then an up.
So that's our backward search.
And it's not that
complicated, hopefully.
If you're looking for
66 or 59, you do that.
So it's much more natural,
and you just need to flip it.
Why am I doing all this?
Well, the reason
I'm doing all this
is that I have to do some
bounding of the moves,
and I know that the moves that
correspond to the up moves
are probabilistic in the sense
that the reason I'm making them
is because I flipped
heads at some point.
So all of this is going
to turn into counting
how many coin flips
come out heads
in a long stream of coin flips.
So that's what this
backward search
is going to allow us to do.
And that crucial thing is
what we'll look at next.
So the analysis itself
is a bit painful,
but there's a bunch of algebra.
But what I want to
do is to make sure
that you get the high
level picture, number one,
and the insights as to why
the expected value or the with
high probability value is
going to be order log n.
But the key is the strategy.
So we're going to
go off and we're
going to prove this theorem.
Our backward search makes
up moves and left moves.
We know that.
Each with probability 1/2.
And the reason for
that is when you go up
is because you got
a heads, and if you
didn't get a heads in you got a
tails, that meant you go left.
Because of the previous
element, every time you're
passing these elements
that are inserted,
and they were inserted
by flipping coins.
So that's key point number one.
All of that, if you look
at what happens here
when I drew this out,
you got heads here
and you got tails there.
So each of those
things for a fair coin
is happening with
probability 1/2.
And it's all about
coin flips here.
Now, the number
of moves going up
is less than the number of
levels-- the number of levels
is one more than that.
And we've shown that that's
c log n with high probability
by the warm-up Lemma.
That's what this just did.
The number of up moves-- I mean
you can't go off the list here.
This list is now you're
not inserting anymore,
you're doing a search.
So it's not like you're
going to be adding
levels or anything like that.
So the number of up moves
we've taken care of.
So this last thing here which
I'm going to write out here
is the key observation,
which is going to make
the whole analysis possible.
And so this last thing it
says that the total number
of moves-- so now the total
number of moves has to include,
obviously, the up
moves and the left
moves, and there's
no other kind.
The total number
of moves is going
to correspond to
the number of moves
till you get c log n up moves.
So what does that mean?
There's some sequence
of heads and tails
that I'm getting, each of
them with probability 1/2.
Every time that I got a
heads, I moved up a level.
The fact of the matter is that
I can't get more than c log n
heads because I'm going
to run out of levels.
That's it.
I'm going to run out of room
vertically if I keep popping up
and keep doing up moves.
So at that point I'm
forced to go left.
Maybe I'm going
left in the middle
there when I still
had a chance to go up.
That corresponds to getting a
tails as opposed to a heads.
But I can limit the
total number of moves
from a probabilistic
standpoint by saying
during that sequence
of coin flips I only
have a certain number
of heads that I
could have possibly gotten.
Because if I got more heads
than that, I would be up top.
I'd be out of the skip
list, and that doesn't work.
So the total number of
moves is the number of moves
till you get c log n up moves,
which essentially corresponds
to-- now, forget about
skip lists for a second.
Our claim is the
total number of moves
is the number of coin flips,
so these are the same,
because every move
corresponds to a coin flip.
Until-- it's a fair
coin, probability 1/2--
until c log n heads
have been obtained.
So the number of
coin flips until c
log n heads is the
total number of moves.
This equals that.
And what we now want to show, if
you believe that, and hopefully
you do because the
argument is simply
that you run out of levels,
that this is order log n w.h.p.
That's why it's a claim.
So the observation is
that the number of coin
flips, as you flip a
fair coin, until you
get c log n heads will give
you the number of moves
in your search, total number
of moves in your search.
It includes the up moves
as well as the left moves.
And now what we have
to show is that that
is going to be order log
n with high probability.
OK?
And then once you do that
you've done two things.
You've bounded the number
of levels in the skip list
to be order log n
with high probability.
And you've said the number
of moves in the search
is order log n with high
probability assuming
that the number of levels
is c log n, obviously.
So it's not that the bottom
one subsumes the top one.
It's the last thing to
keep in mind as we get all
of these items out of the way.
This assumes that there are
less than or equal to c log n
levels.
That's the only reason why
I could make an argument
that I've run out of levels.
So if I have this event A
here-- if I call this event A,
and I have this event
B, what I really want
is-- I've shown you that event
A happens with high probability.
That's the warm-up Lemma.
I need to show you that event B
happens with high probability.
And then I have to show you
that event A and event B
happen with high probability,
because I need both.
Any questions?
We're stopping a minute here.
The rest of the analysis,
a bunch of algebra,
we'll get through it, you
can look at the notes.
This is the key point.
If you got this, you got it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you just say
that because the probability
of drawing an up move
instead of a left move
is 1/2, that the expected
number of left moves
should be equal to the number
of up moves, [INAUDIBLE]
bound the up moves?
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
So the argument
is that since you
have 1/2, can you
simply say that the expected
number of left moves
is going to be the same as
the same as the up moves?
You can make arguments
about expectation.
You can say that at any level,
the number of left moves
that you're going to have is
going to be two in expectation.
It's not going to give you your
with high probability proof.
It's not going to relate
that to the 1 divided
by n raised to alpha.
But I will tell you that if you
just wanted to show expectation
for search is order
log n, you won't
have to jump through
all of these hoops.
At some level you'll be
making the assumptions
that I've made explicit
here through my observations
when you do that expectation.
So if you really want to write
a precise proof of expected
value for search
complexity, you would
have to do a lot of the
things that I'm doing here.
I'm not saying you
waved your hands.
You did not.
But it needed more to
than what you just said.
OK?
So this is pretty much
what the analysis is.
With high probability analysis
we bounded the vertical,
we bounded the number of moves.
Assuming the
vertical was bounded,
we got the result for
the number of moves.
So both of those happen
with high probability.
You got your result,
which is the theorem
that we have somewhere.
Woah, did I erase the theorem?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
It's somewhere.
All right.
Good.
So let's do what
we can with respect
to showing this theorem.
There's a couple ways
that you could prove this.
There's a way that you
could use a Chernoff bound.
And this is kind
of a cool result
that I think is worth knowing.
I don't know if
you've seen this,
but this is a seminal
theorem by Chernoff
that says if you have a
random variable representing
the total number of
tails, let's say--
it could be heads as
well-- in a series of m--
not n, m-- independent coin
flips where each flip has
a probability p of
coming up heads,
then for all r greater
than 0, we have
this beautiful result that
says the probability that y,
which is a random variable--
a particular instance
when you evaluate
it-- that it is larger
than the expectation
by r is bounded.
So just a beautiful
result that says here's
a random variable that
corresponds to flipping a coin.
I'm going to flip
this a bunch of times,
and I know what
the expectation is.
If it's a fair coin
of 1/2, then I'm
going to get m over 2--
expected number of heads
is going to be m over 2.
Expected number of tails
If it's p, then obviously
it's a little bit
different-- p times m.
But what I have here is if you
tell me what the probability is
that I'm 10 away
from the expectation
and that would imply that r is
10, then that is bounded by e
raised to minus 2 times
10 square divided by m.
So that's Chernoff's bound.
And you can see how this relates
to our with high probability
analysis.
Because our with
high probability
analysis is exactly this.
This is the hammer that you can
use to do with high probability
analysis.
Because this tells you as you
get further and further away
from the average or you get
further and further away
from the expectation, what
the probability is that you're
going to be so far away.
What is the probability that in
100 coin flips that are fair,
you get 50 heads?
It's a reasonably large number
because the expected value
corresponds to 50.
So r is 0.
So that just says
this is a-- well,
it doesn't tell you much
because this says it's less than
or equal to 1.
That's all it's says.
But if you had 75, what are
the probability that you
get 75 heads when you
flip a coin 100 times?
Then e of y for a fair coin
would be 50, r would be 25,
and you'd go off and you
could do the math for that.
So it's a beautiful
relationship that tells you
how the probabilities change as
your random variable value is
further and further away
from the expectation.
And you can imagine
that this is going
to be very useful in showing our
with high probability result.
And I think what I
have time for is just
to give you a sense of how
this result works out-- I'm not
going to do the algebra.
I don't think it's worth it to
write all of this on the board
when you can read
it in the notes.
But the bottom
line is we're going
to show this little Lemma
that says for any c,
invoking this Chernoff
bound, there's a constant d,
such that with high
probability, the number of heads
in flipping d log n.
So I have a new constant here.
d log n fair coins,
or a single fair coin,
d log n times,
assuming independence,
is at least c log n.
So what does this say?
A lot of words.
It just says, hey, you
want an order log n
bound here eventually.
The beauty of order log n
is that there's a constant
in there that you control.
That constant is d.
So you tell me
that c log n is 50.
So c log n is 50.
Then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to say something like,
well, if I flip a
coin 1,000 times, then
I'm going to have an
overwhelming probability
that I'm going to get 50 heads.
And that's it.
That's what the Lemma says.
It says tell me what c log n is.
Give me that value.
And I will find you a d, such
that by invoking Chernoff,
I'm going to show you an
overwhelming probability that
for that d you're going to
get at least c log n heads.
So everybody buy that?
Make sense from what
you see up there?
Yup?
So this essentially
can be shown--
it turns out that
what you have to do
is-- and you don't
have to choose 8,
but you can choose d equals 8c.
Just choose d
equals 8c and you'll
see the algebra in the
notes corresponding to what
each of these values are.
So e of y, just to tell
you, would be m over 2.
You're flipping m coins, fair
coin with probability 1/2.
So you got m over 2.
And then the last
thing that I'll
tell you is that what you want
in terms of invoking that,
you want r-- remember we were
talking about tails here-- so r
is going to be d
log n minus c log n.
So you just invoke Chernoff
with e of y equals m over 2.
And what you're saying here
is you want c log n heads.
You want to make sure you
get c log n heads, which
means that the number
of tails is going
to be d log n minus c log n.
And typically we analyze
failure probability,
so what this is is this is
going to be a tiny number.
So the failure is when you
get fewer than c log n heads.
And so that means that you're
getting more than d log
n minus c log n tails as
you're flipping this coin.
Fewer than c log n heads means
you're getting at least d log
n minus c log n tails.
So that's why this
is your r here.
And then when your
r gets that large,
and you can play around
with the d and the c
and choose d equals
8c, you realize
that this is going to be
a minuscule probability.
And you can turn that
around to a polynomial--
again, a little bit of algebra.
But you can show
this result on here
that says that
the number of coin
flips until c log n
heads is order log
n with high probability
by appropriately
choosing the constant d to
be some time/number over c.
So I'll let you do that algebra.
But this one last thing
that-- we're not quite done.
So you thought we were done,
but we're not quite done.
And why is it that
we're not quite done?
Real quick question
worth five Frisbees.
Why is it that we're
not quite done?
What did I say?
I have done event A
and event B, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: I haven't
done the last thing which
is to show that probability
of event A-- this
is with high
probability happens--
and I need to show
that probability
of event A and event
B happens-- or this
is with high probability.
Or I should just say
event A and event
B happen with high probability.
And you can see that.
It turns out it's
pretty straightforward,
but you got the gist of it.
Thanks for being so patient.
And there you go guys.
Woah.